hello and welcome to this video we are
playing Grand Master Gregory or Perrin
why does he have such a bad rating
that's not fair I mean for his standards
he's a 2600 Grandmaster pretty strong
one what are the most promising Russian
players young russian players what the
heck you're young and promising and
Russian doesn't mean you can play
everything what is that it looks very
strange oh yeah maybe see for my cheeks
don't know about how if I can open this
up quickly upon Texas Bishop is three
coming ask you for I mean okay this is
part of it anyway so let's play see form
yeah are 95 directly attacking this
don't know I don't want to play Bishop a
3m right now just want to ask him about
the move and this is this move okay so
if i take and play Queens is six what's
what's going on
[Music]
it looks bad I came yeah rookie one on
Queenie 626 that's probably Queenie
seven marek rookie one looks looks
better so I can take here I'm not sure
that its net not nets all that much but
I can also just take this and continue
yeah can take take stuff now d 5 and so
on what is he doing here I mean probably
we didn't have much better now it check
someone know this one I don't know
Bishop e3 is also also attractive and
there is really no reason not to grab
another porn you still cannot cancel
Knight f6 now if I take on f5 is
probably going to cheek deform and f2
hangs and my routines that I'm not sure
about that that is so great just do this
still just preventing canceling um
should be too unfortunately blunders
stuff should be three maybe [ __ ] too
much behind hear that clock wise but
position is very good
I'm not material up huh that's a kind of
strange it looks like I should be
material of but ok I can win a pawn now
I mean it's not it's not ideal I would
have expected more of it it's what it is
[Music]
hmm that's a connection problem I just
send out a ping ham and this is not
trolling or anything here this he just
has a connection problem maybe I have
the connection problem no mmm my
connection is ok now will I will pick up
a pawn here now at least
I probably missed better things but
after that opening you should probably
get more with them okay black forfeits
due to this connection yeah
unfortunately would have been
interesting to see if I can convert this
in 1 30 i mean i'm not sure converter
Smith strong which it's probably a win
technically speaking so um yeah this is
probably okay with f5 I could have
played this one actually ah so it's even
worse than it then it looks yeah okay
but this is also not bad sure all very
normal i think what i did a 5-4 queen f
was interesting but I should always have
a some advantage next Beck's pawn
structure it's just extremely weak and
this wins wins wins straight away okay
that was even better and estimated that
I Bishop a3 is awesome this is what I
didn't see this one this is of course
extremely strong now and resins I have a
strong one check and I should take f5
okay I was i said i was thinking you can
take here with just Bishop takes okay
because this is hanging very bad IAM and
then
that would have killed me merely until
mean this is still very good but ya like
like this 92 interesting I probably just
would have taken I had this in mind and
then I know some some night development
it's essentially just a flat porn and
like not more not less not clear by kid
witness in and in 1 1 minute 30 okay a
bit of a bit too to lose opening here by
black thanks for watching